do you think you should branch out make
some new friends you never know what
could happen when you guys were choosing
these ladies what made them the perfect
fit for the role we picked sort of five
people for each role and then we
narrowed it down and had chemistry reeds
in LA and Janelle came to one of those
sessions and I just met her on the side
because we hadn't met before and I we we
knew we had to go with Laura Jean first
and then base the family around whatever
that person looks like when Lana came in
she was so Laura Jean in my head I
remember pulling her aside into a
hallway which you're never ever supposed
to do as a director and saying I'm in
your corner this is it you're my Laura
Jean I'm not kidding you throw your hair
in a ponytail let's go back in and kill
this you know and when we did and to
this day I'm so thrilled with that
choice and all the way across the board
what if we let people think that we were
actually together let's do this Noah in
Israel when they came in I was thinking
that they could be either role like I
knew there was a Peter and the Josh in
there and I wasn't sure which would be
which until I saw them with Lana and
then I was like oh he's a definite Peter
he's a definite Josh and then just your
vision came to life it's such a
beautiful talking about what you want to
work on Nicks because this is a dream
team my letters are my most secret
possessions I write them when I have a
crush so intense I don't know what else
to do how much of your real-life
mirrored Laura Jane's life oh so I did
the idea came from my own life so I used
to write love letters to boys when I was
trying to get over them yes and my never
got sent out but I would write where are
they right now that is true in fact when
the book first came out at my first
event I thought it'd be really funny if
I read from one of the letters oh yeah
and then I was like it's gonna be great
and then I got up there and everyone
loved it and I was like oh my god I felt
anti-fade was like on fire I was so
embarrassed and it really is like really
diary because I think for this
in the movie you should have had to go
through the whole experience you know
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]